>> Well the thing that probably that leaders
could do that might help the world is to say
what they mean. In other words, to say that
they're going to do something and do it or
say they're not going to do something and
not do it. And that goes for politicians as
well as businessmen because it's important
that everyone should communicate very clearly.
On the other hand, I think those that don't
regard themselves as leaders need to take
more power into their own hands. Not in the
sense of nagging the politicians and the rich
of this world to do things on their behalf
but to actually do things themselves. Policians
are very fallible people. They don't, they
tend to believe that what they say is what
happens and of course the two are very different.
So I think on balance, they should say what
they mean and the rest of us should do what
we think we ought to do rather than wait for
our leaders to do it for us.